dear guests of the climate ambition
summit
55 that is now indeed
europe's calling card i'm glad that the
27 european leaders have signed up to
the european commission's proposal
for taking climate action to a new level
of ambition
together with the arrangement on our
next seven-year budget
the 55 agreement is a go-ahead
for scaling up climate action across our
economy and society
we have already started from boosting
renewable energy
creating hydrogen valleys and producing
the most sustainable batteries
to launching a wave of building
innovation
decarbonizing transport and protecting
and restoring
our nature we are serious about getting
our economy
on a more sustainable path
but this isn't a task for europe alone
europe only accounts
for less than 10 of global emissions
climate change is more than a european
issue
it is a human issue
and today there is a global movement for
climate action
a movement that counts on powerful
nations
but also on countless cities ngos people
of goodwill
europe wants to contribute to the
movement and make it grow
we want to work with all those who agree
that we must put a price on carbon
we are ready for more ambitious
commitments with like-minded countries
and we are supporting developing
countries to help them
decouple their emissions and their
economic growth
just like we are doing in europe
and it is more than cutting emissions it
is about green finance
it is it is about restoring biodiversity
it is about a new circular economy that
creates
jobs and prosperity while preserving
nature
many things have to change so that our
planet can remain
the same for the next generation
55 percent is europe's contribution on
the road to glasgow
let's walk this road together